hey I'm fine Bob don't worry I'm not by
myself I can't do it I cannot do it nah
oh god damn it all five years of [ __ ]
face is that you in the background Ken
man you look my boobs pumped up you know
yeah it looks so conceited I'm just a
pleased to be here beauty
what are you here are you going to spend
Valentine's Day with Ken cry notice the
flowers and pointed at them are those
freaking beautiful oh no he's up for you
cry was astonished beauty what are you
trying to say I'm trying to say that I I
really liked you for a while now and the
king I may even have more feelings than
like and won't he be mad I mean sad I
think I love you finished beauty I'm
flattered I really am but I have to ask
about
I left can do mr. Turner the floorboards
swirling his thumbs why would you leave
him you two were so happy together well
it seemed like Peter looked up at cry
staring into his eyes I left there for
you I mean him you kept me waiting
friends
I'm sorry oh and cry what is it purely
leaned forward closer and closer to cry
zere cry will you be my Valentine go
into this building there's the best
weapon in the game in this building wait
here your check how dare you
I trusted you do something about it okay
don't hit me over trust I could try to
get you out Oh Oh best weapon in the
game huh best weapon in the game I see
how it is
come here come here and free me come
here and free me Kai yeah cool be cool
be cool I'm cool I'm cool alright I
can't do anything I think you're stuck
for life okay you attention server I
know you found some way you should kill
in the town so if you look on your map
okay he's out
[Music]
that's right you [ __ ] get hope you
bros enjoyed this video thank you so
much 2k automation for making it you can
go ahead and check out his channel here
and subscribe and for more information
go ahead and click here that's all
stay awesome breasts
[Music]